hi I'm Patrick beta video host evalute a
man weekly and today I want to talk to
you about the mistakes startup
entrepreneurs make when it comes out to
negotiating
so many times when your startup
entrepreneur or you know your
salesperson whatever it is your 1099 you
started your own business you know you
learn the skill of sales and you're
taught by somebody who's teaching you
sales a lot of times as an amateur
you're told go for the best steel you
know you hear lines like go for the
throat and close them and get as much
Commission as you can and do this and do
that and as a rookie entrepreneur you
start negotiating extremely aggressively
right and what ends up happening is you
feel good about yourself you go home
feeling like you got a victory but
there's something else taking place that
you don't know but I've learned this
from my life and from my own personal
mistakes over the years on what is
really the proper way of doing this and
I learned I learned later on when it
comes on to negotiation okay when two
people are involved in a negotiation or
three people are involved if one person
wins one person loses
that's not proper negotiation because
what will take place is the person
losing will probably not do business
again with the person winning now on the
flip side when is a good negotiation
good when it really you say well this
was a pretty good deal it's either when
both are happy about the deal or when
both are not happy about the deal let me
explain two could say you know what I'm
not really happy about the other person
can say I'm not really happy about the
deal that means nobody really got the
shorter end of the stick they both
worked on a number or something and
there is a compromise they're not
necessarily disappointed because the
other person took advantage of them
they're just not happy that the deal
wasn't the best deal they got right or
they both walk away this I got the best
deal possible let me kind of give you an
example of you know the difference maybe
of a Jerry Buss or a gym bus right Jerry
Buss you know expert he built the team
he did what he did and what mistakes
maybe gym bus make so you can kind of
get an idea about negotiation look at
Jerry bus you know Jerry bus at Pat
Riley come up to me and say you know
what New York Knicks offered me eight
point something million dollars what do
I do with them and Jerry's like I can't
afford to pay you eight eight million
dollars you got to do what you got to do
right and you know Shaq comes back and
he says I want twenty eight million
dollar I want twenty two million dollar
urine you know Jerry says I'm not going
to pay you that because I'm going to go
more with Kobe than I am with
- and sometimes when you do that short
term you take a hit but long term you
win you know after Pat Riley came Phil
Jackson right after Shaq came to Saul
and a couple other role players and they
still want a couple championships Kobe
ended up and ending up with five and
Shaq's got four rings and that's
something that's talked about but look
at it today right I mean did Kobe really
the contract that he just signed with 48
million dollars when they asked him and
they said would you be willing to take
less money to get talent coming and his
answer was no I'm gonna go get all the
money that I can is what his answer was
even as a veteran he said that now some
may said well you know what that's what
he needs to do not if you want to win a
championship if it's purely for money I
understand but if you want to win a
championship it's not going to happen
and so Jim buss may have given him the
money with Jerry Buss have given him the
24 million year I highly doubt it I
think 16 17 maybe 18 I don't see Jerry
giving 24 million dollars who would have
said listen you can still retire a Laker
but we're not paying you 248 million
dollars you can go to the Bobcats or you
know somebody else they'll give you the
contract so then you look at a store
like the Miami Heat you hear LeBron
James wanting to go to Miami here Dwyane
Wade's champion he's already got a ring
LeBron doesn't they bring Pat Riley Pat
Riley talks to Wade says take less money
Dwyane takes less money he makes
Bosh come over he makes LeBron come over
three years later they went to
Championships but why did that happen
because Pat Riley is not a start-up
negotiator Pat Riley has been around
he's willing to sit down and talk to
everybody and you know what this ended
up doing for doing Wade by the way he
lost money initially but you know how he
made a lot of money endorsements
commercials name TV he's all over TV
because everybody's interviewing the
champions the champions and they're
saying Dwyane Wade how does it feel
being a three-time NBA champion right
and as a start-up entrepreneur you're
gonna if there's one thing you're going
to need to learn is you're going to need
to learn how to negotiate how to
communicate how to sell and not the way
that it's only good for you a way where
everybody wins that they keep coming
back to want to do business with you
that's my message of the week TM please
be sure to subscribe and share this
video
you